that comes from a story about uh Nelson
Mandela Nelson Mandela is a very
important leader because
um different leaders of you differently
depending on where you go but Nelson
Mandela is universally regarded as a
great leader no matter where you go
that's true and
um he was asked by a journalist once how
did you learn to be a great leader
and he told the story of when he was a
boy
um he was actually the son of a tribal
chief
and he said he remembered going to
tribal meetings with his father and he
remembers two things one they always sat
in a circle and two his father was
always the last to speak
and if you think about it even
well-intentioned leaders we come in and
who sit at the head of the table
you know
and we say to the team okay here's the
problem we have this is what I think we
should do but I want to know what you
think
too late you buy us the room or you've
made people feel like their opinion
doesn't matter as opposed to sitting
down and saying here's the problem I
wonder what you think and then
being good at having a poker face you
can ask questions but not giving away if
you agree or disagree
and at the end you can have the exact
same opinion as you came in with but two
things happen a you actually get the
benefit of more input right
um so you actually may change your point
of view and
other people feel like they could
contribute ever feel like they were
contributing because they because they
were right
um so yeah it is a fantastic practice
um to literally practice being the last
to speak